l'alliance netanyahu campe verra bel et
bien le jour
la décision de la cour suprême met fin à
dix sept mois de crise politique dans le
pays et ce en dépit de multiples
manifestations d'opposants à cette union
aussi inédite qu'inattendue
selon la cour la désignation de benyamin
netanyahu au poste de premier ministre
n'est pas contraire à la loi
malgré les trois chefs d'accusation dont
celui de corruption qui pèsent sur lui
quant aux accords de coalitions
présentés par les deux rivaux la cour a
jugé inutile d'intervenir à ce stade les
entendre car cours futurs demeurait
possible
benyamin nétanyahou et benny gantz vont
donc pouvoir prendre la tête du
gouvernement à tour de rôle 18 mois
chacun pour des raisons d'équité les
portefeuilles ministériels ont été
respectées au sein des deux
gouvernements
mais pour les israéliens opposés au
projet cette décision est contraire aux
valeurs morales du pays
nous ne sommes pas ici pour la justice
nous sommes ici pour défendre des
valeurs morales nous voulons juste
rappeler qu israël a été fondée sur des
valeurs très moral
si nous les perdons nous perdons
benyamin nétanyahou est il vraiment un
premier ministre à la morale condamnable
l'analyste politique yohanan plesner
estime que si cette décision de la cour
suprême
hérode le combat contre la corruption
elle reflète aussi l'opinion d'une
majorité d'israéliens altimètre les
finalement la cour suprême a décidé que
d'un point de vue légal
une intervention de la cour n'a pas lieu
d'être pour empêcher la volonté de la
majorité des députés du parlement dans
la désignation de monsieur netanyahu
pour former le prochain gouvernement
rod décision ralenti notre combat contre
la corruption mais elles reflètent
l'opinion d'une majorité d'israéliens
qui connaissent les accusations contre
monsieur netanyahou et qui néanmoins
veulent à la fois le voir former un
gouvernement et tenter de se blanchir
des accusations devant un tribunal
ce nouveau gouvernement justement va
devoir très vite s'atteler aux dossiers
brûlants et le premier des deux à s'en
charger n'est autre que benyamin
nétanyahou en pleine crise sanitaire de
covin 19
le leader historique de la droite
israélienne va tout d'abord devoir se
concentrer sur le redémarrage de
l'économie et le déconfinement
progressif engagé depuis ce lundi
la routine nous avait vraiment beaucoup
manqué je vais vous dire une chose le
pain est quelque chose de très simple
mais cette chose magnifique m'a
tellement manqué je suis heureuse de
pouvoir aller au centre commercial à
nouveau peur nous pouvons reprendre nos
habitudes je pense que nous sommes en
bonne santé
le corona virus ne m'inquiète pas et ce
n'est pas tout car à compter du 1er
juillet un autre dossier brûlant fera
son apparition sur le bureau du premier
ministre
le plan de paix au proche-orient
présenté par donald trump est d'ores et
déjà rejetée par mahmoud abbas